tell us about going to the
and what that screening was like amazing
our dear president came in and met with
us before the Pitt film and was
absolutely wonderful in so complimentary
of the film and he's had the girls read
the book and everything which was so
great wow what an honor to meet our
president he was just really lovely
that's so great so you got this part but
you weren't an actress at the time you
were nine years old when you got the
part how did that all come about my mom
had been an actress with the local town
and gown theater they had heard about
the movie people coming to Birmingham
so James Hatcher who was head of the
Little Theatre called my mom and said
well maybe you should bring little Mary
down and she's about the right age and
the coloring is right and so my mother
had to go ask my father and get
permission from him to bring me in and
of course my dad said no now my mom had
daddy totally wrapped and she's like now
Henry dear what are the chances the
child will get the part anyway
Monroeville had changed so much there
were you know a lot of the homes had
been torn down and there were wires and
paved streets and that sort of thing but
I think also that it wouldn't have been
safe for them to make the film there I
was very very sheltered but what you
have to understand is times were very
different then we had a little black and
white television set that sat on the
kitchen table and it was only turned on
for weather and back then we only had
two stations
and they weren't even on all day the
rest of the time it was just fuzz how
many of you remember that you know it's
like you know today and this is what's
hard when I talk to the school kids
because you know today we have 24-hour
you know seven days a week non-stop news
and we didn't have that and the things
that were going on down in Birmingham in
the city we had no knowledge of it you
know as to what was going on and I'm
sure even if they did they kept us well
away and kept us safe I didn't find out
a lot of things that went on in
Birmingham until I read a school mates
book Diane mcquarters book carry me home
it's one of the best histories written
of my city Birmingham Alabama and I was
in New York doing some school kids there
from what they call a last-chance school
these kids had been and scrapes with the
law and they introduced them to To Kill
a Mockingbird and she had them read the
book and showed the film and the gal
that I was staying with was good friends
with Diane and she said I have a
surprise for you in that dynamic order
is going to be here and she has come to
see you and so I was very excited to see
Diana hadn't seen her for years and in
talking with her about the book have to
came very nervous because I had heard
some things at home there were people
that were very upset with what Diane had
written and we're all in there everybody
is in there and all the families that I
had grown up with and I went to Diana I
said you know was daddy a good guy or a
bad guy you know I mean was
where was he and all this and she said I
never read anything but good things
about your father and all the people
that I talked to had nothing but
positive things to say I was like sure
you know that's a big relief they had
decided to do the film all on the
backlot of Universal Studios and Henry
Bellmon said who was our wonderful set
designer had found period houses that
were being torn down to make way for I
believe it was one of the freeways and
so he had all these houses sent to the
studio and drew up these wonderful plans
for this village I was doing a Vanity
Fair shoot some years later just a few
years back and they my driver was so
excited he said well I'm a tour guide
here at Universal and we go to your
street we get requests for that a lot so
it's like real excited or like oh this
is great you know so the car pulls up
and comes to a stop and he says how does
it feel to be home like I'm looking
around and I don't recognize anything
and I started to cry and when I got out
of the car one of the guys realized what
had happened and he came over and put
his arm around me he said they didn't
tell you did they and I said no and he
said one of the guards became
disgruntled about something and he
burned most of the backlot down and your
house was one of the first that he
torched so what you see over there at
Universal is only partially what we had